à cette photo c'est sans doute la
dernière photo de maëlys vivante donc
pour l'obtenir
tf1 a eu des documents issus de la
procédure et donc c'est purement et
simplement une possible infraction
pénale punie d'un an d'emprisonnement et
de 15000 euros d'amande et donc à une
enquête des gendarmes le procureur comme
vous l'avez dit norvez 4 s'est manifesté
et si vous par exemple vous continuez à
la diffuser et bien nous sommes dans le
recel de violation du secret
professionnel
ah ouais donc vous pouvez effectivement
être puni donc par précaution je
comprends tout à fait votre décision
même si c'est un document incroyable
c'est une infraction pénale alors les
images de la reconstitution elles sont
incroyables aussi regarder on découvre
alors le parcours et la version 2
nordahl le landais bien
sûr ces images inédites que nous nous
sommes procurés on découvre nordahl le
landais lors de cette reconstitution
barbus vêtus de noirs ici sur le parking
de la salle des fêtes où se déroulait le
mariage la voiture du suspect kit
d'abord les lieux nordahl le landais
explique aux juges que malisse se met à
pleurer qu'ils paniquent et lui donne
plusieurs coups au visage il les
reproduit sur cette photo la fillette
décédera accidentellement juste après ce
long il conduite ensuite les juges
jusqu'à l'endroit où il dit avoir
abandonné maëlys une première fois puis
jusqu'à sa salle de bains où il se
change avant de repartir au mariage pour
se forger un alibi
alors je vous dis tf1 a diffusé les
images sans flouter les visages mais
nous on a été obligé par la chaîne et je
crois que c'est normal un gilles de
flouter les visages cas il est encore
présumé innocent n'a pas loin en fait et
volé le dit marianne tf1 flûte et le
mannequin qui représentait la jeune
fille la petite fille maëlys mais
n'avait pas floutés nordahl le landais
c'est ça voilà c'est ça qu'est ce qu'il
faut comprendre aussi c'est que le
procès va s'ouvrir le procès pour le
meurtre de la petite maelys ouvre le 31
janvier des documents comme ça dans
l'esprit de la justice au delà du du
fait de les obtenir sans doute
illégalement ça peut influencer la
décision donc ça peut être très grave
parce que c'est un procès que tout le
monde attend plus on l'émotion que ça
suscite donc du coup enfin moi
personnellement je trouve vous avez très
bien fait de flouter honnêtement quoi
mais c'est quand même un très gros scoop
delà de la part de briller enfin mais
franchement on n'a pas tapé sur eux à
fleurs ou quasiment suis d'accord à
grandes affaires judiciaires se passe
dans les mains il est tout le temps des
révélations des documents qui sortent et
je pense qu'il faut être honnête
n'importe quel média qui auraient eu
accès à ces documents à ces images ont
été très contents de les sortir bizarre
qu'on leur tape dessus surtout tf1
devait le savoir dont ils ont voulu
prendre le risque pas sûr je suis pas
sûr qu'il le savait mais les services
juridiques béton armé s'assure à mon
avis quand vous mettez un truc à
l'antenne et jeudis vous n'appelez pas
le service juridique géraldine je pense
que vraiment ils sont même pas posé la
question je pense qu'ils sont 10 à mon
avis on peut le faire et ils ont pas ils
n'ont pas vérifié avant ce passage et
wii puis ça dépend de leurs sources
aussi et peut-être qu'ils ont une source
qui leur a dit tu peux y aller on sent
on connaît pas des sources c'est réel
c'est soit l'une des deux parties soit
un enquêteur qui l'aura qui a dit tu
peux y aller et qui peut-être les a
trompés et puis c'est vrai que c'est un
document je ne conteste pas ce que dit
guillaume circulation exceptionnelles
mais ces problématiques et c'est très
rare qu'un procureur ouvre une enquête
du chef de violation de secret de
superman fessionnels c'est vraiment très
rare à l'encontre d'un média s'est bien
essayé d'aller faire folle vraiment
loyal et certains ont émis l'hypothèse
que l'on dit n'agirait pas seuls ferait
partie d'un raison on en est où ben ça
ça avait été beaucoup beaucoup actionner
alors là haut niveau 2 du procès pour la
petite maëlys et pour deux autres
infractions sexuelles il sera jugé seul
et ce qui est incroyable c'est que
incroyable aux censeurs horrible étrange
horrible c'est qu'il risque la
perpétuité réelle avec une période de
sûreté qui ne serait pas de 22 ans mais
qui est une période de sûreté total
c'est à dire que c'est ce qui s'était
passé pour michel fourniret il risque ça
c'est à dire qui ils sortiraient s'il
est condamné à ça jamais de prison donc
je dis pas que c'est problématique mais
ce sont des peines qui depuis 1994 n'ont
été donné que trois ou quatre fois le
pnb bon moi j'entends ce que dit gilles
j'entends ce que dit guillaume c'est des
journalistes ils sont dans le métier etc
etc moi je trouve ça dégueulasse pour ça
honteux les documentaires comme ça tf1
20 heures on ressort des images d'une
petit mensonge je pense aux parents je
pense à la famille tué lui-même du mal à
respirer si si on l'avait fait ça ma
fille on voit nordahl le land à côté et
j'entendais présumé sans une aux
innocents elle est là elle est dans sa
voiture on a trouvé du sang dans sa
voiture mais moi j'ai du mal à dire
présumé innocent c'est qui alors elle
était dans sa voiture on n'a plus jamais
revu la petite moi je dis honte atef ils
ont des enfants tf1 le mais les mecs qui
sont dans les bureaux quand ils font
leurs les documentaires quand ils disent
ça on va le mettre à l'antenne ils ont d
ces gens-là guillaumie dit ouais mais
c'est comme ça mais peut-être dur mais
n'a pas d'enfant le jour où tu auras des
enfants si on touche à ta fille comme ça
et que tu vois tf1 le 20 heures toute ta
famille tous que ça engendre on va voir
la tête que vous allez faire quand on
votera vos enfants au 20 heures elle est
partie d'affilée on la reverra plus
dense et finir elle est morte en wave
ouvrez les yeux faut arrêter cette
passion comme ça c'est de la merde
mais cette rencontre l'histoire oui mais
je comprends ce que tu n'es pas dans
l'émotionnel l'assemblée magot sont là
font enlever toutes les émissions
finie la russe avait mis mais alors il
est 21 janvier sur comment éviter on
parle d'affaires fait qu'il était de
faire cet honneur de deux de mes excuse
moi de 31 janvier le procès commence là
maintenant tu passes un truc comme si
tous les médias font ça ne joue pas tous
les ménages ne devrait pas faire juste
rémois là là là effectivement il ya
l'émotion c'est de la barbarie c'est au
delà du supportable on est d'aller mais
simplement pour toutes les affaires de
faits divers dont on parle régulièrement
ici tu pourrais dire la même chose
ne sont pas finis il ya une tradition
française qui est de par les défis sont
faits divers parce que les gens sont
passionnés mais pas forcément au centre
angevin jeunes gens qui lisent mettez
vous à la place des familles oui il
quand tu es dans le nouveau d'effectifs
quand tu es dans des trucs faites entrer
l'accusé à 23h quand tu es dans des
programmes liens et messi est peut-être
tu décide d'y aller regarder ce
programme là sur des faits divers sur
des meurtres personne décide le 20h ya
marqué le vainqueur moi je veux pas de
ce torchon là dans mon 20 heures je veux
pas que cette torche on l'a dans mon 20
heures mon batteur tu me donnes de
l'information tu me fais pas du
voyeurisme avec une gamine qui a été
lâchement assassinés par un peu je vais
je vais insulter c'est pas la peine je
fais insulter c'est quoi c'est quoi ces
trucs là après je vous comprends votre
position vous êtes journaliste c'est
bien on voit là vendu un documentaire et
les gens ils vont venir ils vont
regarder il ya des endroits pour faire
ça moi je procède 31 janvier la petite
malice on la voit dans la voiture à
prendre la voie plus jamais pensé à la
famille deux minutes et et mettez vous
dans des rôles de parents et de pair si
je pète un câble en fait ça
mais j'entends mais là c'est un sujet du
20 heures c'est que tout le monde a
envie de connaître plus on l'a fait avec
d'autres affaires
mais tu as raison effectivement c'est
une petite fille s'est tu as raison on
doute bien que c'est lui qui a qui
voient là il est présumé innocent blood
c'est tout ce qui n'est pas innocent ça
c'est un fait maintenant pour le coup
ils font leur métier ils ont un scoop il
ne diffuse le composent mais voilà que
par rapport à la sensée tf1 le 20 heures
personne voile excusé avant pour dire
bonjour ne fait pas c'est que dans les
émissions de pdo la séparation par dont
celles activées avec l'émotion de santé
mentale et je comprends parfaitement
mais le journaliste que c'est pas ça
lasse et de l'enquète il avait un scoop
énorme c'est une vraie constitution
alors bien sûr effectivement c'est
horrible mais là c'est justement ce qui
permet de voir la barbarie c'est ce qui
permet d'avancer aussi et toutes ces
affaires sont au régent attendent aval
gilles muller toutes ces affaires sont
horribles alors bien sûr accepterait
pour une personne mais c'est un scoop
énorme pour tf1 qui montre la barbarie
l'histoire est évidemment qu'il fallait
le diffuser évidemment tu te trompes le
savent a été de me dire nordahl le
landais il est coupable parce qu'on a
trouvé ça en plus ça c'est un scoop mais
on va accepter
raconté un truc qu'on a déjà qu'on
connaît déjà qu'on a déjà vu me faire
voir une photo d'une fille aurait
raconté c'est normal
il ya zéro ce couple adam même votre mot
le scoop le scoop pour une gamine qui a
été qu était assassiné le scoop arrêter
les mais qu on redescend et on se remet
les choses en place y'a pas de scoop à
faire là dedans y'a pas de scoop à faire
avec une gamine qui a été assassiné par
un par un prédateur tu vas finir sa vie
ont fait que sept mètres dans ses
comptes à montre bien que raconter les
choses et les voir c'est différent la
barbarie tu viens de l'avoir ici ce que
fait tf1 c'est bien et c'est ce qu'il
fallait est ce que c'est la menace est
très dur et son papa donne 20 heures
mais bien sûr c'est la planète à 14h30
c'est là qu'il fallait faire pour gagner
je suis désolé
mais parce que c'est là parce que c'est
de l'information c'est parce que c'est
le moment l'information le jt de 20
heures c'est toujours des moments
malheureusement quand tu pourras jt de
20 heures raymond 90% c'est des
mauvaises nouvelles et à la fin c'est
vider par la météo c'est ça le jt de 20h
en effet d'annoncer la barberie les
erreurs du monde d'en prendre conscience
c'est ça et c'est le rôle des
journalistes
31 janvier la le procès commence le 31
janvier il est présumé innocent si vous
voulez pour les gens pour la justice
parce que y'a la justice en france
maintenant la dernière fois qu'on l'a vu
c'est avec lui le sens qu'on a trouvées
dans le coffre celle sans malice bon
allez stop ya pas à chercher des secours
plus loin on laisse faire la justice est
si vous voulez faire des enquêtes table
si tu voulais pas qu'ils voulaient faire
c'est celui qui est viable ça n'engage
que moi ça n'engage que mes propos que
la tunisie mais ça n'engage que lui je
m'en fous ça n'engage que moi c'est moi
je dis ce que je pense maintenant
maintenant vous voulez faire des
reportages pas de problème laisser faire
le procès un petit peu laissé avancer le
procès et après si vous voulez on fait
des faites entrer l'accusé on fait plein
de trucs si vous voulez sais aussi que
je ressens moi en tant que père on en
aurait fait ça ma fille tf1 tf1 passe un
truc comme ça sur ma fille je ne sais
même pas ce que je fais je sais même pas
si je vais pas en bas de chez tf1 pour
faire une bêtise c'est leur en tant que
père je parle près on peut avoir le
débattre en 30 heures on sera jamais
d'accord